what is your message to those people who
want to go in protest who will
inevitably break social distancing rules
to do so and also the small number of
people who are content on doing damaging
disruption well what I would say to
everybody thinking about this issues I
totally understand why people feel
outraged certainly about what happened
in in Minnesota and the death of George
Floyd everybody understands people's
legitimate right to protest against the
discrimination against racism in our
society and I think this is a country
that has made huge progress in tackling
racism and you know we should look
sometimes at the positive stuff you know
we've got more young black and minority
ethnic kids going to university than
ever before more black kids doing the
toughest subjects in school doing better
than ever before in school we don't hear
enough of this positive stuff and what
makes me sad about what's happening
today is that you've got a situation in
which the statue of Winston Churchill
who is a national hero has had to be
boarded up for fear of violent attack
and that to me is both absurd and and
wrong you should not have a situation in
which people who are protesting over on
one rope on one basis are violently
attacking the police or public property
and I'm afraid what's happened with
these these demonstrations is that a
tiny minority or actually a growing
minority unfortunately have hijacked
them and they are using them as a
pretext to attack the police to to cause
violence and to cause damage to public
property
so my unfortunate my message to
everybody is that for all sorts of
reasons they should not go to these
demonstrations and whatever our feelings
about the cause we should not support a
demonstration that is in all probability
looking at what's happened before going
to end in deliberate and calculated
violence so I'm afraid that isn't that
is my mess
but we will continue to make progress as
a society in tackling racism because
that and that's that and that is the
substance of the issue and a very good
question on the those that do commit
disruption that do clean violence lots
of people watch trap and last week and
we're appalled by what they saw and
didn't feel like the authorities came
down hard enough on those people so what
are you going to do if people do commit
instruction damage this weekend are you
going through anything extra anything
more police wise or with the courts to
make sure those people have thoughts
adjusted well the I saw the police this
morning and they've already made
hundreds of arrests in in the last few
few days and they will make many more
because believe me they are they can see
the culprits the culprits may think that
they've got away with it but they
haven't but is overwhelmingly they are
being recorded with with body-worn
camera and we will bring them to justice
and they will face the full force of the
law it is not acceptable in this country
to attack a police officer it is not
acceptable
to set out in a calculated way to do
damage to public property let alone to a
statue of Winston Churchill so that is
the approach we will take